this episode is sponsored by Ren a
website where you calculate your carbon
emissions you can also sign up to make a
monthly contribution to offset your
admissions or support rainforest
protection projects by clicking on our
Link in the description
[Music]
[Music]
if I were to ask you to just do a little
sketch of what you think of when you
hear the phrase Moss animals you might
imagine something like this tardigrade a
waddling slightly Fantastical creature
that we did in fact find living within
the minuscule Greenery of moss
but depending on who you are and what
you know maybe you draw something
completely different maybe you draw
something more like this
these don't really look much like an
animal at all do they at first glance
they seem a bit more like plants with a
stalk connecting a series of flowers
with thin elegant petals but no that is
indeed an animal one that has the
dubious honor of being defined largely
by its anus
before we get there though let's start
with just explaining what these animals
actually are these organisms are members
of the phylum bryozoa a name that
translates in Greek to Moss animals but
bryozoa aren't actually animals that
live in Moss they get their name because
of what they look like when all of the
elegant individuals you see here
congregate into colonies that look you
know Mossy
that giant gelatinous mass seems to Bear
little resemblance to the tiny Winsome
creatures that make it up but ryozoa are
notable in the animal kingdom because of
just how Colonial the phyla is around
the world and Waters salty and not are
colonies of different shapes and sizes
made up of individuals like these these
colonies can get their start in
different ways some might be the result
of sexual reproduction sperm and egg
that could have met in the waters away
from their makers or in other cases one
Colony may have captured sperm released
by another using it to fertilize its own
eggs which stay brooding until a larva
emerges ready to set out and develop its
own colony
but bryozoa have another asexual option
for reproduction instead of fertilizing
an egg a colony can amass a bunch of
cells into a structure like this one
called a stata blast
these statoblasts can be so prevalent in
our samples that James our master of
microscopes has to scoop them out to
keep them from being the main focus of
our videos they are thick and durable
able to lay dormant and protect their
contents from cold temperatures and dry
weather but when the conditions become
right again they grow into a new
individual that will form the basis of a
new colony
to do that the individual bryozoa called
a zooid navigates the waters as a larva
eventually attaching itself to some kind
of solid surface perhaps a piece of rock
or some kind of shelf maybe even some
seaweed and from there it will begin to
divide budding off but keeping its
descendants close and connected as they
increase in number
the arrangement of the zooids dictates
the shape of their colony as does the
material they secrete to support the
colony overall some excrete a gelatinous
material that turns them into those
masses of jelly we saw earlier others
rely on kindness materials that give
them more rigidity and as they spread
over their surface and even grow up into
the water around them bryozoa colonies
take on many spectacular shapes
even though bryozoa are different from
Coral they definitely look similar and
like Coral bryozoa colonies don't move
instead they remain attached to their
service but while they may not be able
to move through the world around them to
gather resources bryozoa are able to
make the most of their surroundings with
individual zooids taking on special
functions that allowed the group to
accomplish more than the individuals
some focus on making eggs while others
form small beaks that allow them to snap
at predators and these zooids are all
dependent on another group of zooids
that gather food and share the nutrients
with everyone else
to get that food the feeding zuoids rely
on the loaf of four the Ring of
tentacles crowning every zooid's bodies
that looks a bit like a bunch of thin
petals or a very elegant duster those
tentacles are covered in cilia which
circulate the waters around the briozoa
stirring currents like the ones you see
here so that it can sweep bits of food
like Plankton toward the animal's mouth
and from certain angles you can see how
the lovophore and the rest of the zoids
organs tuck into a sort of casing which
is a structure called the cysted and
while the briozoa has various other
parts that we could talk about what
we're really here for is the anus which
is a much bigger deal than you might
expect from an animal with such a simple
digestive system there is a mouth an
esophagus and then a U-shaped gut that
leads to the anus
and then the issue has really rooted in
the existential crisis at the heart of
microorganisms how are things related to
each other and what does that mean for
the names that we give to things
organisms like these were originally
given the name polyzoa in 1830 but that
was changed a year later to bryozoa by
the German naturalist Christian
Ehrenberg but as more organisms were
added to the group the people watching
them and describing them realized that
they were actually lumping together two
very similar groups of organisms that
actually had some key differences
between them and one of those key
differences was where the organism's
anus was located one group had their
anus situated just outside of their loaf
of four that tentacle Crown we were
watching gather food earlier and one had
their anus situated just inside their
loaf of four so to differentiate between
these two groups scientists gave them
very appropriate names one group was
called ectoprocta which translates in
ancient Greek to outside anus and the
other were called the endoprocta which
means inside anus because you can Define
anything by its butt as long as you turn
to ancient languages in general bryozoa
typically refers to the ectoprocs though
for many reasons I can't possibly
imagine why briozoa seems to be the
preferred name but the history and
relationship between the ectoprocs and
endoprox remains an ongoing mystery that
scientists continue to explore
they are certainly not the only animal
out there to be wrapped up in a
phylogenetic mystery but isn't it great
to know especially for such a strange
animal like this that the mystery is
built on butts
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you again to
Ren for sponsoring this episode of
Journey to the micro Cosmos Ren is a
website where you can calculate your
carbon emissions then offset them by
funding projects like Community tree
planting in East Africa or a project
that helps prevent wildfires in
California by removing dead and
flammable trees and turning them into
biochar we will need a lot of different
approaches to take on the climate crisis
and this is one way that you can learn
more about your carbon contribution and
take some action you'll answer a few
questions about your lifestyle and
they'll also show you ways that you can
start reducing your carbon emissions of
course no one can reduce their footprint
to zero but using Ren you can help
offset what you have left once you sign
up you'll receive updates from the tree
planting rainforest production and other
projects you support also we have
partnered with Ren to plant 10
additional trees for the first hundred
people who sign up using the Link in our
description
thank you so much to all the people on
the screen right now they are our
patrons on patreon they said to
themselves one day you know I think that
content about tiny tiny organisms and
the whole ecology and world that is just
beneath our view really deserves to
exist and so they became our patreon
patrons and you can do that too at
patreon.com journey to micro if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss check out jam
and germs on Instagram or Tick Tock and
if you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
foreign